hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game also from the super
United rapid tournament currently being
played in Zagreb Croatia it is
for those who haven't been following the
previous games uh this is the lineup for
the tournament so yanipo Michelle
Fabiano
Magnus Carlson even
and Anand already uh played two games
this is a game from round three he has a
drug installer is a one win against
lupolescope and this is his game against
the Rapport so let's check it out and
then we are going to discuss everything
that's happening in the tournament but
also uh here uh I've prepared this for
you to enjoy look at this beautiful
photo by Leonard Otis uh this is uh the
world champion is not even in this photo
these are all three former World rapid
World classical Champions Magnus Carlsen
we found in the Gary Kasparov uh they uh
defended their World Church championship
titles uh together 15 times so that is
absolutely incredible uh let's enjoy the
photo uh for a little bit and now uh
let's check out the game so uh Anand has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to E4 uh he knows that of course the
Rapport was being second in his world
championship match against janipong so
he has to be careful about what he plays
he knows that if anything maybe a
rapport is even uh the the most uh well
aversed in uh theory of all the players
here so uh we have pawned the C5 rapper
goes for the Sicilian Defense Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 uh
truly people go for C3 and Bishop to B5
very rarely will we see the open D for
Sicilian it's just uh it's just too too
aggressive black has too many options
there so here one to E6 and now the
incredibly rare continuation Pawn to C3
here the standard moves are casts and
Bishop captures and C6 but Anand
obviously uh trying to be very tricky he
plays Pawn to C3
so still the a line of the Nish medino
rossolimo attack but uh uh very much a
sideline we have Pawn to D5 and this is
the reason e Captain D5 Queen captures
on D5 now can be played as the C3 square
has been vacated and then uh taken by
the C3 Pawn now and you cannot kick away
the queen and gain a free Tempo with
Knight to C3 so okay uh castles by Anand
we have Bishop to D7 into Rook to E1 at
night to F6 and now there is a game
where Knight to A3 was played uh it kind
of makes sense you want to play Knight
A3 maybe put an item C to put the Knight
on E3 kick away the queen but here we
have Bishop back all the way to F1 and
it is now as of 8 that we have a
completely new game so obviously Anand
has something very tricky in mind with
Bishop to D6 uh rehab continuous
development and pawn to D4 we have
castles and now H3 uh C captures on D
for C captures and Knight the E7 the
Knight can now be uh shifted over to
Jesus sword F5 if needed but also the
bishop can be put to this diagonal to
put pressure on the white king but uh or
as you've already seen the bishop is on
F1 so Anan doesn't have to worry about
any Checkmate threats uh happening along
this diagonal Knight to C3 and this is
already a second game not in a robot in
the last few videos where we have the
bishop on F1 just doing such a
remarkable job of everything uh we have
Queen to A5
uh and now Knight the E5 by Anand we
have Bishop to C6 here if you try
something like Knight to C6 it is very
dangerous yes of course you would enjoy
if Knight captures Bishop captures but
imagine something like Bishop G5 now
threatening to mess up the pawn
structure in front of the king lets the
bishop characters D captures Knight D5
and now the uh very annoying Queen G4
with some nasty threats uh you don't
want this against a player like Anand so
Bishop to C6 instead and now Bishop to
F4 we have Bishop to B4 uh and the
unjust nicely placed Pawn to A3 he
doesn't mind giving up the C3 Pawn as uh
he will gain a lot of activity for it
but the rapper decides against capturing
it with Bishop capture spawn captures
and now he just ignores it the the
reason is if Queen captures on C3 after
Knight to C4 look at this queen uh the
knights takes away the A5 square and uh
it I mean just they're looking at Rook
Rook D3 uh I mean you don't want to play
this it is possible to play it of course
let's say Knights the G6 but you have to
know the position you attack the bishop
and I've Rook D3 you attack the White
Queen okay this keeps black in the game
but if you don't know it you don't want
to play it so immediately Bishop to A4
attacks onan's queen queen to F3 now
puts pressure on the pawn on B7 and here
you might expect something like Queen to
D5 offering a queen trade
or even just putting a knight on D5 but
rapper plays Rook 8 to C8 and he offers
the B7 Pawn so can Anand capture this
yes he can he plays Queen captures on B7
now comes Knight E to D5 and now Bishop
back to D2 guarding the C3 pawn and
while you could capture it again uh you
don't you don't want to have this uh on
your hands let's say queen B2 attacks
the Knight here and if not after D5
there's even Knight to C4 now attacks
the queen and next move you capture the
Knight okay it's not lost or anything
you can still play with something like
Queen A6 Bishop captures and C3 and The
Rook captures on C4 uh but it's uh you
know not great okay Bishop captures
Queen captures Bishop before you rub the
exchange but still not uh not maybe the
the best uh option so instead Rook the
B3 uh attacking the queen we have Knight
the C4 uh very important sufficient to
going after the queen on A5 Queen back
to d8 and now Queen captures an A7 Anan
gobbles up another Pawn Rook day 8 we
have Queen to B7 and now Rook to be a
but now Queen to A6 and now of course
Rook to A8 will be met with Queen to D6
saurabh tries Bishop to B5 uh still
Queen to D6 by Anand we have Queen to C8
and now Queen to C5
uh this is uh the correct choice of uh
moves because if you just move the
Knight then you can capture an F1 you
can put the Rook on B2 it's going to be
incredibly active the bishop here will
be undefended so Queen to C5 is the the
best move it does double your pawns but
uh Anand is confident that he can make
it work so the uh Queen captures on C5 D
captures and now Bishop captures on C4
with Bishop captures and Rook F to C8
you know okay uh Rapport is done
material but uh the the two po the two
pawns are on the C file uh if he can
pick off at least one of them he should
have a decent drawing chances but still
that's a lot of work we have Bishop to
F1 and it immediately offers one uh but
there's always time to capture the
rapper goes for activity first with Rook
to B2 Bishop to C1 as the bishop is
undefended this is the best uh move uh
Rook the C2 now going for uh after both
of the pawns and now Pawn to C4 the
bishop again doing the incredible work
from F1 uh you know from the starting
Square that's how good
uh this uh this square is for the bishop
we have Knight D7 and now Pawn to a for
now and starts pushing his past a pawn
of the board Knight to C6 with Pawn to
A5 and now Knight to D7 going after the
C5 Pawn so Bishop to E3 defending now
both of the Bishops nicely defending the
uh the the two pawns and now Knight D to
E5 we have Rook the A4 uh adding more
defense to the C4 pawn and Rook to A8
now putting pressure on the A5 Pawn but
Anan just advances it pawn to A6 we have
rooked the B2 and now uh we'll try to
trade off works with Rook to B4 but now
Rook to D1 we have rooked the B4 and
just Rook D to A1 of course Alan wants
to keep his Rook on A4 Rook the B3 and
now Pawn to G4 preparing to even get to
the bishop now with Bishop at uh G2 very
interesting thing the bishop and move 39
that's uh that's a classy we have Bishop
Pawn to G5 and Bishop to G2 Now The Rook
obviously cannot remain an A8 but it's
uh hard to find moves here uh we have
Pawn to H6 Now Pawn to A7
as the the A7 point is nicely guarded by
the Rooks we have rooked the B7 now
tripling up the attack against this A7
Pawn uh but now there are a lot of moves
that are uh winning for Anand and he
chooses uh a very direct one he plays
Pawn to F4 and he was in this position
on move 41 that arapot resigned in the
game as there really is nothing more to
be done here so there we have it there
was no pause the video or anything a
moment because uh rapper tried going too
aggressive against Talent he he started
sacrificing pawns and uh okay Anand is
uh one of the few players in the world
where where that will not um uh actually
work for you it doesn't matter how
strong you are doesn't matter if you're
a rapper doesn't matter if you've helped
the ding prepare for the wheelchair
championship match Anand is just too
strong so the point is here you resign
because now that this diagonal opened up
we've reached a position almost from the
thumbnail uh and unleashes his Bishop
pair from hell and now after as the
Knight is saying you can't really move
the Knight because this Knight hang
things so you're gonna have to capture
but now you have the same problem how
are you dealing with this and after you
start capturing let's say Rook captures
an A7 you can just trade everything up
captures captures and captures and now
the problem is both of your Knights are
still hanging and you have to recapture
The Rook otherwise you're just down too
much material so let's say We'll capture
Sierra Bishop captures here and you have
two Bishops against the Knight you rub a
full piece of course completely winning
so Robert saw this and after Ponte F4 he
resigned the game but also he burned an
incredible amount of time throughout the
entire game and unfinished the game with
some seven minutes on the clock Rapport
was down to a few seconds so I mean
that's just how complicated the position
was uh full of potential you know Anand
could do this he could do that it was
merely a matter of time before the the
bishop perform hell comes to life and
for those of you who are now interested
in the standings here are the standings
Anand is leading after three days of
Rapid in Croatia uh with two wins and
one draw followed by Magnus Carlsen and
yang shito Duda and the rehear rapper
with four points Fabiano caruana even
charged with three points
with two points and in last place
Constantinople with uh with one point he
only got one draw uh so yeah very
exciting uh start of the day uh we'll
see what happens Anand says that he is
very happy with his plane on the first
day and that he will see if he will be
able to continue playing at such a level
but I mean uh okay it's probably gonna
come down to his game against Magnus but
he he he's just playing incredible chess
and looking forward to seeing what he
what he does next and this was just I
mean a rapper tried uh you know a a
funky line on and said nope not today
and that was pretty much it that's the
story of this game uh so yeah uh once
again really hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank James Eugene Cashman John
Austin uh not complete bullet just
thriller.com and Paul Miller for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering this tournament until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day